[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪♪
♪ THE D.J. IS BUMPING ♪
♪ SNOW OUTSIDE.
>> THERE'S TURKEY AND FRIES.
WE STILL GOT BARACK
SO WE SHOOTING SOME HOOPS IN
HIGH WAIST JEANS.
>> LET'S SPREAD SOME CHEER ♪
♪ IT'S THE LAST CHRISTMAS WITH
BARACK STILL HERE ♪
♪ THE LAST CHRISTMAS ♪
♪ BARACK'S STILL HERE.
>> KIDS ENJOY THE PRESENTS WHILE
YOU CAN ♪
♪ NEXT YEAR YOU MIGHT GET A BOMB
FROM IRAN ♪
♪ WE'RE STUFFING EVERY STOCKING
WITH LEGAL WEED ♪
♪ GET MARRIED TONIGHT ♪
♪ AND LET IN EVERY IMMIGRANT IN
SIGHT
THE NORTH POLE DISAPPEARS.
>> LAST CHRISTMAS ♪
♪ BARACK'S STILL HERE ♪
♪ LAST CHRISTMAS ♪
♪ BEFORE TRUMP NEXT YEAR
OH, SNAP ♪
♪ EVEN JESUS IS GETTING DOWN
DANG, JESUS, I DIDN'T KNOW YOU
WAS A DEMOCRAT ♪
♪ THIS YEAR I BOUGHT BOTH
CHRISTMAS TREES ♪
♪ BOUGHT HOME ALONE ON DVD ♪
♪ GOT BATTERIES ♪
♪ EVERYTHING I NEED ♪
♪ THERE WILL PROBABLY NEVER BE
ANOTHER CHRISTMAS EVE ♪
♪ BEEN DRINKING EGGNOG LIKE I
DON'T CARE ♪
♪ GONNA HURT MYSELF BEFORE I
LOSE OBAMACARE
GOT OBAMA BACK SMOKING NEWPORTS
AGAIN ♪
♪ LAST WILL AND TEST.
♪
♪ FOR THE FIRST MAYBE LAST BLACK
PRESIDENT ♪
♪ I'M DECKED OUT IN SANTA GEAR
HEAD TO TOE ♪
♪ THEN I NOTICED PAPA WASN'T IN
FESTIVE CLOTHES.
>> HE SAID NEVER TRUST A WHITE
DUDE WEARING NO RED HAT ♪
♪ LAST CHRISTMAS ♪
♪ BARACK'S STILL HERE ♪
♪ BEFORE TRUMP NEXT YEAR P.M.
HERE I GO ♪
♪ HERE I GO AGAIN ♪
♪ GIRLS WHAT'S MY WEAKNESS ♪
♪ JOE BIDEN ♪
♪ MAKES ME FEEL FUNNY ♪
♪ WANT TO TAKE A FREAKY RIDE ♪
♪ WE COULD SHARE ICE CREAM UNDER
MISTLE TOE
JOE SNUGGLE UP FOR A FOUR YEAR
LAP ♪
♪ JINGLE BELL ♪
♪ JINGLE BARACK
LAST CHRISTMAS WITH OBAMA ♪
♪ SO HUG YOUR BABY MAMA ♪
♪ AND DO THE JINGLE BELL ROCK ♪
♪ JINGLE BARACK ♪
♪ DO THE JINGLE BARACK ♪
♪ LAST CHRISTMAS WITH OBAMA ♪
♪ SO HUG YOUR BABY MAMA ♪
♪ MIGHT BE THE VERY LAST
CHRISTMAS ♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]